you
oh I should probably hit join I've done
that before I've wondered why am I not
pairing me up
and it was because I forgot to adjoint
hello Jason thank you
oh this one jumped you right up on me
there's a small crew for an hourly
Boulud arena a 27 minute tournament one
minute chefs
all righty I'm going to baby step it
pretty symmetrical gotta go a little bit
slower let's let's sneak this in there
preserve my bishop from Knight h5
castles where will there this is
completely symmetrical this is where it
now changes mm-hmm let's jump in here
Knight takes Knight I take the Queen
might be tempting or not keep the
structure
is taking with the bishop I guess will
play here I want to keep the flight
square open
and now the plan will be to place c4
right now get to take here and I'm on
the bishop and now I get to saddle my
opponent with let's start with this
isolated pond how is that defended like
that 9c2
seems pretty deadly hitting the rook and
d4 I get to take ones checking on the
bishop now that's a check this should be
annoying now come in exchange one rook
now am i winning the ending here I think
I am oh there isn't a rook here I had
that move actually so this is a
backbreaker take there just put my pawns
on dark and don't lose on time it's the
only thing
up upon and the exchange just improve
the king now I get the night or the pawn
I will gladly just take up that tricky
night and I like where my rook is keeps
the King cut off I'm going to yeah I
wanted to pave the way for my King to
enter here I could continue to march and
I could push through here I'll have a
past H pawn soon you get that in there
and another one and just scoop the
bishop up in the pond and back determine
you know there's also another adjustment
recent adjustment with the rules and
maybe you'll see this take effect but
yeah one of the adjustments is that if
you have just a bishop remaining and
your opponent has a bunch of material
you know pawns your opponent has mating
material they're now considering just
having a bishop as mating material if
you could if there's some way to
organize let's see let's focus here for
a second if there's some way to organize
a mate with just the bishop then yeah
they're they're awarding you a win I'm
dropping b2
oh that's a better move develop defend
be to pressure on d6 you need to back up
get some trades in there not d6 wasted a
lot of time it's free up my night let's
get my knight here threatening mate
I could take here oh and then get my
king over the night still can't move
okay I can win that now flush that King
out of there oh why am i giving that
pawn up I don't have seven
seconds six seconds four seconds three
seconds I have a pond they can move oh
man shut up about the rules in play oh
man okay anyhow you could win with just
a bishop or a knight there that's what I
meant to say in too many words try
Sicilian
all right we like to think Etta with the
Queen Bishop there let's throw the H
pawn down you know have a knight on f3
let's open it up this is going to be
sensitive yeah
kind of scary I'm prepared to give it my
rook for the bishop no boy okay
thought that night was pretty annoying
let's get my King out of there Knight
here still a move keep a keep a rook on
ya you have that I have this I'm on the
night ng3 now Bishop takes pawn to Maine
three four and let's go here here that
would have been a better way to defend
let's keep the cleans on my night could
be kicked I'm going to play d4 I'm
playing this really stupid
my Queens defending here I rook has that
come back over here
let's get rid of this night huh should I
can I clean that g4 so I have this
advance Bishop is pinned oh my goodness
what a killer fall I'm on that rook
maybe wasn't a killer fork after all
maybe it wasn't a killer fork but we go
here we're getting the Queen where's the
mate there it is back to tournament land
there we go
you got eight who else is in here we got
a crew of 61 right now just under 20
okay this is the pack leader he's in
there 12 d4 d5 e6
wow that's different
mm forgot that that was truck app I'm
down upon castle I could play this this
seems better though I think I have to
stop that pawn from pushing bishop
here's a threat now ooh okay
not so clear oh I didn't mean to do that
I could have just went here straightaway
oh boy those nights are just so
dangerous mmm yeah he's got to go
can't deal with that guy hmm I want to
take an up
the h-file I'm doing a very poor job of
trying to convert this very sad on the
bishop maybe now take care
I want one rook off so coordination is a
bit more difficult
let's take care
clean back Bishop g4 boo that I didn't
see now I am just worse I want this pawn
to get rolling so easily my Bishop
offsets the night ah very poor technique
oh no I was on the rook I'm gonna get
mated ah man oh my god I drew that I
drew that oh man my structure was so
wrecked structure aside though there
should be no way I allow that to even be
a draw and in the end I was lucky her to
be a drop one more to say play better
chassis dummy play better chess all
right throw a jab in there a jab mm I
guess we'll take now Bishop to b4 and
say no soup for you let's take here
let's see if I can convert a game can we
convert a game if we're winning the
Queen now huh if I lose this quitting
I'm quitting chess all together I got
the Queen alright that was a fairly
quick win trying to get back on the
horse here with the fire he's got fire
he's game just finished might be getting
pear yeah we're probably going to get
paired up with this guy there we go
another top Doug he is a four point lead
maybe we go fishing
so I forget about going fishing on the
chess board mm-hmm expand let's get that
guy out of there it'll take
let's make sure it's closed seems scared
to just go pawn grabbing there let's ask
him a question yeah I don't know that
feels right
so now
who could take that now it's a very open
position here multiple captures in the
air now let's go here and I think I want
to jump in here soon now let's just push
it take once there isn't yeah there is a
night move what's check okay let's get
out of that okay let's get a queen trade
in there up some material on the night
as well how am i saving that pond not
really saving it really saving it they
could take on f7 let me have 11 seconds
I'm playing very slow that's a good way
to
your bishop even eat him why Jeff why
why I don't know what to say oh man oh
man it's scary it's very scary I wish I
had a bishop he's really not around oh
my god they didn't take my rook did I
win
yes i won a bishop he did it I was going
to be able to weave a mate somehow from
that position
give me the W we got another game shut
up c4 oh man
okay yeah that Bishop was dangerous you
need to get rid of him
that's mating material now it's mating
material he was going to go crazy town
and we've a mate oh look at this
preserving a bishop like that why I'm
the one with space alright we're going
we're going to go for f4 and they're
going to try to kill me on the H file I
need to close things up just a hair I
think no security five this guy won't
open up the H file anymore there's
nothing to buy tap now there's Knight g4
good irritating let's go here I feel
like I need to stop Queen h4 they're
going to pick up the exchange if they
want umm hear this okay
Oh clean they're so dangerous let's push
I think this is okay
and then ooh that move man so much time
is wasted here
this is very scary very scared I could
get hit with a fork at any moment at any
moment the Queen trapped maybe 11
seconds my first threat amazing a check
I could take out this night I'm just
going to do it for keep things simple
yeah no time I've mating material
definitely okay first as 20 19 18 18 18
is where I'm at
okay 76 players in there okay um it's a
bit early isn't it alright I'm going to
take and push try to hang out of that
guy mmm let's give a check get the
Queen's off I'm going to tape it tonight
okay I'm fine with this let's try to
keep the structure safe hmm yeah okay so
now I could do this safely let's get him
out of here get out shoo let's go here
it's just going to bother me now I have
this okay I think everything's fine now
get the rooks
here here let's just expand a little bit
I could push
maybe maybe e5 is a move they have to do
that
this is too much how they getting that
pawn back though to give up something
like this but he still lives I'm going
to get this in hmm okay I want to hang
on to my pawns in the center they could
go after my a pawn but who cares about
the a pawn who cares about them I'll go
here I have this covered let's get
something off here I could trade nights
I want my King on d5 so I could push umm
start with that I start running with the
a pawn I don't know if I was able
catch the puns if I played Bishop there
I take my paw
to run they still might try that though
okay now stalemates man no stalemates
I could push through with that holy cow
down to the wire again they were down on
time oh man
28 23 22 is where we're out sky again
it's my third time plying him okay yeah
you did that last game what's the story
with this oh I'm playing this wrong this
is not good
Bishop to b4 is the way to try and take
advantage of this and I'll try to hang
on to him yeah you're going to kick my
night away I'm on the bishop for the
moment yeah okay
better bishop and like a keen on this
square take with the queen i want to
keep this square open for a piece so can
I get my knight there I should have gone
here I had to defense my bishop and a
flight square ok I'm going to depo I
didn't see that happening but they're
just going to go pawn hunting so that's
what I wanted to be
now let's activate my Brooks yeah and
what now
and now could I get away with that steak
what's check hmm oh yeah just go into a
fork huh boy it's scary it is scary
bishop
yikes they're just on my night I get a
mate
oh man you time burning machine.you
oh my goodness ah man down I go I got 22
I have to have to be a sneek artist now
man why am I just in a position where I
have to be reacting to my opponents
threats I played that opening terrible
for starters this c3 move or f3 move
what is f3
give me that Bishop I need them see I
could convert this in a clean way can I
get a clean win in there that's all I
want
one clean win can we get that let's see
we're going to find out where's the
trick where is the trick up a piece
let's not get too crazy with that pre
move right here is a main threat let's
see if Lee moves so that night here is
just game over
well it'd have to move Knight to b3 come
on
square now making to threat the rook
okay they resigned back determine pretty
quick when Lu 24 top is 36 I feel like
this guy would just roll me right over
with how I'm playing right now
36:27 24
all righty the Dutch playing really fast
going to give me the e5 square stake
here and then here and then here we're
going to jump in to e5 how I guess with
this guy Bishop here let's give that
check can I rely upon my queen as a
defender of this Knight Wow aren't these
bishops going to be animals and to go to
the other square clean exchange they're
playing super quick I should just take
that night out and play against the
structure I'm not winning a piece no
winning a piece watch out for my back
rank who just a free rook making three
whoa whoa I'm glad it wasn't me that
father was dangerous if I was one rule
short if I was one move short that guy
was going to sneak right by and hit me
with a dagger a dagger he's going to
give me a little jab and it was going to
hurt really bad oh man that's me keep on
this guy you sneaky - that's a pawn sack
look at those guys and take my beep on
you are so greedy now it's the right
thing to do here's the plan don't let
this guy move that's the big plan
okay now we're trying to torture we're
just trying to torture or now we're
really just trying to torture I get in a
four there's a problem I could do this
so you hear they're okay they freed up
the bishop oh they have that move their
bishops still kind of dead huh let's get
a flight square you probably need a fly
square at some point huh now we're going
to go here take and then I get to give
check force him away and then you push
order order order
move order they resign back to terminal
where are we at 140 left in the
tournament thirty nine thirty I'm just
trying to hang on a second there's no
catching first he slipped up too okay
that makes me feel better
tough guy he yeah he slipped up too I
don't feel so bad about my loss now yes
I do I wanted to win them all I don't
know why I'm going for this same line
let's try to do something with B for not
happening so now my rope just looks kind
of silly huh oh you didn't want the C
pom why didn't they want my C pawn so
mystery could have captured here
they're probably asking me why I don't
want their daepung anyone
man 1 now you see it so the H pond down
make the Jeep on flinch going from a
here
pretty move whoo got it and I'm not
going to get paired up again am i it's
going to turn blue at the 30-second mark
is that how it's happening
29-28
yeah tournament pairings are now closed
okay that's going to do it one little
hiccup there well really huh I like more
than one hiccup got second place there
42:34 2925 very lucky with the net one
win sorry my voice cracks everyone
surrounds still recovering slightly
anyhow having just that bishop he's
apparently mating material I guess
there'll be some instances where the
remaining pieces when you just have like
a bishop are tonight there won't be a
way to organize a mate with certain
pieces so yeah and you know I guess it
checks for that anyhow 83 you know let's
see all the pages 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
already to the 82 of you good games Oh
already
you